NOW IT'S TIME TO PLAY WHY IS
THIS VLOGGER CRYING?
(APPLAUSE)
ONE OF THE MOST MYSTIFYING
TREND IS PEOPLE RECORDING
VIDEOS OF THEMSELVESS CRYING
AN PUTTING THEM ON YOUTUBE
FOR THE WORLD.
EVERYONE HAS TO LET THEIR
SADS OUT SOMETIMES BUT
SOMETIMES THOSE TEARS FLOW
FOR RIDICULOUS REASONS.
COMEDIANS, I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU
A VLOGGER, AND FOR 250 POINTS,
YOU TELL ME WHAT RIDICULOUS
THING THEY'RE CRYING ABOUT.
FIRST ONE --
IS HES CRYING ABOUT ONE
DIRECTION'S NEW MUSIC VIDEO OR
EVERYONE BEING TOO MEAN TO
JUSTIN BIEBER.
YES, RHYS.
>> WHO GIVES A [BLEEP]?
(APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: THE CORRECT ANSWER
BEING...
>> I'VE BEEN WATING MY WHOLE
LIFE, FOR LIKE, FOR A MUSIC
VIDEO LIKE THIS.
>> THIS IS WHY WE DON'T HAVE
THE INTERNET IN NEW ZEALAND.
BULL (BLEEP).
NEXT ONE.
IS HE CRYING ABOUT HIS
GIRLFRIEND'S HAIR WEAVE OR
THE "GLEE" FINALE.
KYLE.
>> IT IS EITHER RACIST OR
HOMOPHOBIC.
(APPLAUSE)
>> WHICH ONE IS IT?
>> THE "GLEE" FINALE.
>> Chris: LET'S FIND OUT.
>> I CAUGHT THIS BITCH WITH
HER WEAVE OUT.
IT IS LIKE, [BLEEP] BOY.
I CAN'T BELIEVE I'VE BEEN
[BLEEP] THIS BITCH FOR MONTHS.
>> HE'S NOT FEELING ANY GLEE
AT THIS PARTICULAR MOMENT
ABOUT HIS GIRLFRIEND'S HAIR
WEAVE.
>> CAN WE POINT OUT AT HOW
WHITE THAT CAPTION IS BY
TELLING US IT IS A BLACK GUY
AND THEN CLARIFYING THAT
WEAVE MEANS HAIR IN
PARENTHESIS.